foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI why is theft such a big
issue for us and how can we keep our
staff safe
[Music]
and we meet the members of an under-14s
football team who got some coaching from
one of the best players in the world the
first time I saw the Rebecca last
gobsnap
[Music]
hi there this is your Weekly News show
FYI where we bring you all the latest
info on all the big stories yep we've
got loads going up this week but first
Maya how safe do you feel your stuff is
at school I'm talking about your bike
your laptop your dinner money and your
phone I think my stuff is pretty safe at
school I mean we've got a huge gate and
a security guard so I'd hope it's safe
well listen to this because police in
our cities has said that thieves are
targeting kids coming out of school
mainly for their phones Thomas has been
investigated
[Music]
chords on camera thieves stealing bikes
outside of school sometimes in broad
daylight
some thieves even on mopeds go after
belongings as pupils head home from
school more than 600 police officers
have actually been stationed at schools
to reduce crime but that's not a lot
when you consider that there are more
than 30 000 schools across the country
could the police be doing more
are safer School officers
they told schools to offer advice on how
to stay safe from crime so why don't we
see any police officers outside our
schools surely police officers on patrol
would be the best protection for us I
think seeing police inside School makes
it easier for kids to obviously approach
us it breaks down a lot of barriers why
don't we see many officers patrolling
the streets I'm not going to sit and say
you know we've got enough police
officers we need more police officers do
you think it may be because of cutbacks
or spending it's probably a lot of
factors has to work why there isn't
enough police on the streets you know
spending yes it could be a factor but
it's not the only issue the more police
we have on the street the better for
everyone living in London and obviously
in the county forces as well
while many of us may never experience
crime the advice pupils across the
country are being urged to take up is
this be aware of your surroundings
stay alerts thieves also use bikes and
mopeds to snatch phones and valuables
when walking keep valuables out of
sights headphones can be a distraction
use transport that other peoples are
using and avoid shortcuts in isolated
places
[Music]
you might have noticed there's been lots
of news about migrants and refugees
trying to reach the UK by crossing the
English Channel so we wanted to figure
out what exactly is going on
so they have reached France after
fleeing countries across the Middle East
and Africa and they are using small
boats to try and reach the UK it's
really dangerous and usually involves
criminal gangs of people smokers helping
them it's been going on for years but
the number of people who have made the
journey so far this year is nearly 40
000 compared to the 28 461 in 2021
now here's the issue many are fleeing
war or danger in their home country and
genuinely need our help but others are
simply hoping for a better life they're
taken to migrant centers until better
accommodation can be found while their
case is investigated
but the system has been struggling to
cope
check out these pictures of a girl
throwing a message in a bottle over the
wall of a migration Center to
journalists the letter asked for help
and describes the conditions inside like
being in prison
for now coaches are taking migrants and
refugees to other centers to ease the
overcrowding but the route over how to
deal with the English Channel Crossings
seems far from over
now for years FYI has been reporting on
how some of you guys have been sent home
from school for wearing your hair in a
natural afro style well from now on
things are about to change as pupils
with afro hair will be protected by law
against discrimination a new guidance
has been released to schools by the
equality and Human Rights Commission
whose job is to make sure anyone in the
UK is treated equally well we're joined
Now by Kyla who took part in world
afrodia back in September alright Kyla
so thank you so much for joining us and
obviously it's great news isn't it but
am I right in saying that your school
supported you from the start
well when I started the movement in my
primary school it was very encouraging
and very supportive how specifically
were they supported well we always had
world after a day and in black history
month we had a week dedicated to a
certain person and a certain moment in
black history so what's it been like
having afro hair growing up there was
never really enough representation for
afro her children and I was very unhappy
with the way I looked in how my hair
looked I think it's definitely gotten
better but I think we can always improve
with more like afro characters it was
always Elsa and Anna yeah definitely so
how much of a struggle do you think it's
been for others with afro hair I think
many of the struggles been have been
like people trying to touch your hair
and commenting on it and I think some
advice could be to always just be
yourself and never let anybody else tell
you how it should be that's really good
advice thank you so much for joining us
Kyla see you later
[Music]
so while loads of world leaders have
been meeting in Egypt for cop27 to
discuss how to tackle our climate crisis
we thought some of you should have a
voice on how to save our planet there
are loads of amazing things that
everyone can do from large-scale
inventions to just everyday changes that
we can all make to do our bit for
example have you ever thought about
where your food comes from here's one of
the UK's youngest environmentalists in
each War
[Music]
food what we're eating isn't harming the
planet
well one idea is to grow food in your
garden like this pear tree
and my mum and dad have made me a
greenhouse let's go and look at it
whoa this thing is very Lush and I think
I found a cucumber there he is he hasn't
been blocked off yet I know a lot of
people don't have Gardens like ours but
you can even grow stuff in a window box
like strawberries baby carrots or even
salads
one of the reasons our climate is
changing is unlike my pairs most of our
food has been transported from all over
the globe think of all the ships all the
lorries bringing our food into our
supermarkets they use fossil fuels like
diesels that is really bad for the
environment
to show you what I mean I'm gonna do a
little experiment down here we have a
load of things that my mum and dad have
bought from the local supermarkets and
over here we have a map of the world to
show where everything comes from so
these green beans are from Kenya okay
let's leave it there let's get a pin and
let's put it right in Kenya so what do
we have next
we got kiwis from New Zealand that's
really far away
apples
from Italy asparagus is yes from Peru
that's where parenting lives a cucumber
from space
and tomatoes from Morocco that is so
weird because we already have tomatoes
in my back Garden
so how many miles have all this fruit
and veg traveled to get to my house well
I've been doing some songs on my dad's
calculator and guess what
to
1
590 miles
about the same distance as traveling
around the world
four times wow there's got to be a
better way to get off of it right well
maybe we just need to build a greenhouse
like mine but make it humongously huge a
bit like
this one
this is one of the biggest greenhouses
in the UK just outside Norwich it's the
same size as 26 football pitches I've
never seen anything like this before in
my life
the man who owns this place is called
Chris and I really want to ask him some
questions
how can a giant Greenhouse like this
help to save the planet because by
growing uh like this we can save 60 of
carbon emissions by not importing food
from other places
where are there different ways why this
place is eco-friendly well what we do we
Harvest every drop of rain water to feed
the plants and because of this we hardly
use any pesticides and then there's one
other big secret that you have to go
down the road to see that that sounds
very mysterious
huh why have I been brought to the local
storage works
when you've lost your toilet at home
when you have a shower the waste water
ends up at a place like this it's a
little bit stinky but I don't know what
this is about with tomatoes and
cucumbers
so those crops in that glass house they
require heat to grow and the amazing
thing is that when we have treated water
on this site we take the heat from that
treated water and send that to The Glass
House did you say the heat from our way
is used to grow salad that's an amazing
fact so when you flush the toilet that
comes to this site as as dirty water and
then it's got heat in there and we use
that heat for those crops to grow
is amazing
so the heating system in the greenhouse
is using hot water though the other ones
have been wasted it's basically a way of
growing healthy food that isn't causing
as much damage to our planet
if every country does this it will make
a huge difference
now we've got some really exciting news
we've got a new presenter This is
Jeremiah and he's joining the FYI team
here he is now to tell you a bit more
about himself
hi my name is jarai and I'm going to be
presenting for FYI this is going to be
one of my first times going into this
video come with me
[Music]
some things you should know about me is
that I am a bastard young presenter I
won the competition I love dancing I've
been dancing ever since I've been in my
mum's belly ever since I've come out
I've just loved moving to the music what
was that anyway
foreign I'd love to do for FYI would be
about the conflict in Congo a lot of my
family are there so it means a lot to me
[Music]
and don't worry you'll be seeing jariah
again very shortly but first Braden you
play football right yeah could you do
some extra training maybe from a pro
what do you mean well imagine this
you're in a team and it's under 14s and
the goals just aren't happening and then
in walks one of the best players in the
entire world that's exactly what
happened in a new TV series called save
our Squad and the player we're on about
is only David Beckham he steps in to
turn around the fortunes of The Westward
boys who hadn't won a game all season
here's jariah with more
[Music]
thank you
this is where all began for David
Beckham playing in the under-14s league
right here in East London he went on to
play for some of the biggest clubs in
the world and play for England his
20-year career has some Ops and downs
but he is by far one of the best days
we've had Beckham has returned to East
London to try Hal Patton on the 14th top
which is at the bottom of their league
but this isn't just any lead it's the
one he played in when he was 14.
[Music]
I grew up in East London this is where
it all began for me Disney's save our
Squad sees David Beckham faces biggest
fitty challenge yet
all right boys
turning around the fortunes of Westwood
boys FC who desperately needs help the
under 14 side haven't won a single game
in the season Westwood boys they are the
team at rock bottom we're losing
constantly ain't now I know
good I'm at Kuro Orlando and Geo at the
launch of the series I am dying to know
what it was like to have David Beckham
as a coach first time I saw David
Beckham I was cold snap as soon as I saw
him I fell off the seat in the children
it was it was well to see one of like
football's biggest icons walk into the
room is it's another feeling what advice
would you give to anyone
wants to play I think you should just go
for it because at first I didn't like
football at all like when I was younger
but when it hit like seven eight I just
started trying after you eventually fall
in love with the game if you want to do
it follow your dreams but you can't go
in half-hearted like you have to pay all
the effort to get the full outcome that
you want this team is a community
[Applause]
off the pitch Stephen Beckham gets to
know the place families to find out more
about the challenges they face and one
of the most diverse parts of the UK for
him to go on a whole professional career
and then come back to give back to the
people that are in this community is is
one of the main things like so thank you
thank you so much for letting me you
guys interviews been such another
and if you want to catch more FYI just
head to our webpage at first.news
forward slash FYI
well that's it for today see you next
time bye
[Music]